hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well in book 5
chapter 28 of his meditations Marcus
Aurelius is going to say something that
actually sounds a little bit funny at
first and it has to do with how we ought
to respond to other people's
failings ways in which they offend Us
and other people ways in which they
ought to know better and ought to be
addressing so the question is does it
help anybody for us to get angry at
those people and to to behave angrily
towards them is that going to fix the
situation or should we adopt a different
approach a rational approach and Marcus
is going to tell us yes we should use
reason it doesn't mean that we should
only reason with them there's a lot of
latitude for how this would take place
but instead of getting angry we ought to
work with them as a fellow human being
and so the example that he has here is
of bad odors right so it could be a bad
smell literally a goat smell
in in there right so that's not good to
smell like a goat if anybody's ever
smelled goats that haven't been washed
recently you know exactly what we're
talking about but we could imagine all
sorts of other kinds of bad smells that
people's bodies May exude or the person
has bad breath Oxo Tomos and so you know
Marcus says don't be irritated at
people's smell or bad breath and
actually it's more than just being
irritated he's actually telling us don't
get angry
right so this is coming from orge the
word that actually means the emotion of
anger all the way from irritation to
rage so you know you're sitting in
public transport or an Uber or a taxi
cab or you know in a classroom next to
somebody or in a restaurant you get
whiff of them you're like oh geez that
person's ripe what's going on here you
shouldn't get angry at them instead you
should adopt a different approach and uh
you know One initial way of thinking
about it Marcus says kind of humorously
is listen they've got that mouth all
right that's stoma right those
particular
armpits and so that's probably where the
smell is coming from so of necessity
ananke he says this is the Greek word
for necessarily or uh you know it can't
go any other way
so the translation here is they're going
to produce that order and the word
that's actually used there is for
yielding like an investment they're
going to yield that kind of smell it's
going to arise it's going to develop
it's going to happen from them and
that's you know just physics it's
chemistry it's biology it's the way
things work it's the way the universe is
organized people don't wash up if they
don't attend to personal hygiene they're
going to stink and there's really no two
ways about that I mean they might get
lucky for a while and not stink but
sooner or later they're they're going to
develop a ripe odor and so you know you
could look at this as well this is just
the nature of the universe but then you
can make a response you could say well
sure but these aren't just animals these
are human beings
human beings
ought you know as a human being they
possess this faculty of Reason logos
this is what differentiates us from the
other animals so you know they're
capable as he says of thinking things
through dunatai is being capable and uh
you know they can actually exercise
their minds they can wrap their heads
around it quite literally thinking
things through thinking why don't people
like me why you know maybe I do smell a
little bit bad right maybe I should do
something about it they can think about
the offense or irritation or problem
that they're creating and the the Greek
here um play melee is really quite
interesting because it has to do with
um not harmonizing well with other
things screwing up for example a song
right
so here you know they have a brain can't
they figure it out can't they recognize
the problem as a human being they ought
to be able to recognize a problem
so Marcus says to himself and to us his
readers well
you also have reason you also have logos
so you know you shouldn't just get angry
as a sort of stimulus response sort of
thing you should not behave just like a
mere animal either
he says you have a brain brain as well
good for you use your logic to awaken
his quite literally move kineson right
uh uh change alter
a rational disposition logike diathesis
each person has a
possibility for using this this rational
part of themselves take your rational
part use your rational part and move
that other person's rational part get it
to respond to your own as best as you
can this is what you should be trying
not just yelling at them not shaming
them not arguing with them you know
angrily or anything like that and he
says you know show the other person or
demonstrate to the other person dakeson
display to them remind them recall
things to their mind
help them to understand
the situation that they're in a lot of
times when people give offense they
don't realize what they're doing and it
can be helpful to have somebody else
approach them in the right way if you
just get angry at them then they're
probably going to be defensive and
they're not going to be cooperative with
you you're not actually helping yourself
you're not helping anybody else you're
not helping the offender within the
situation by losing control of your
temper instead you have the opportunity
to appeal to this higher part of them
the rational part by using your own
rationality in how you engage with them
and if you do this it's not a guarantee
right but there's a much greater
possibility for something positive
coming out of it so he says you know if
this person listens to which is not a
guarantee then you can actually help
them
says this is a a term that we get
therapy from right so you can guide them
to a better way you you're actually
serving them in the process and this is
a very interesting thing for an emperor
to be saying to himself about how he
should treat other people so
show him make him realize it right
that's the recall it to mind if he he'll
listen then you've solve the problem
without using or making recourse to or
you could say making your tool anger
anger
is use what it is that you're doing how
it is that you're dealing with the
situation so anger is not a good tool
for dealing with people who have bad
odors or we could extend this to so many
other things somebody is annoying in the
sounds that they make as they're you
know thinking about stuff somebody
leaves their things out in everybody's
way somebody takes up more space than
they ought to again in a situation like
public transit or
um you know they're doing things that
they shouldn't be doing like uh standing
in the window and picking their nose or
something like that if you uh you know
if you see people doing this just
yelling at them is probably not going to
fix things get them to see how it's not
a good action or a good condition for
them to be in and you know if they're
reasonable enough they will change it
and you will have benefited them rather
than just having hurt them embarrassed
them made them angry in return and so
this is a you know kind of a funny
example right but it is a very wide
application to the kinds of mistakes
that people characteristically make and
the kind of offense that they typically
give to other people within the fabric
of their relationships whether these are
personal or you know workplace or being
together in the same room or anything
like that so there's a lot packed into
this and to bring this to a close what
he's saying here is use your rational
faculty rather than relying on anger as
a response or as a tool to try to get
other people to change their behavior if
you want them to change you've got to
appeal to this rational part of them and
the only way to really do that is by
using your rational disposition your
faculty of Reason yourself